[Music]
welcome everybody I'm Alexander Rossum
the executive director here at the long
now foundation tonight is a little bit
different of a format if it wasn't
already apparent tonight we're gonna do
a fireside chat whenever somebody says
they're doing a fireside chat there's no
actual fire it really bothers me so we
brought an actual fire for a fireside
chat and this is so we're gonna start in
conversation we have a lot to get
through just to get through the basic
story here of what's going on with the
long term stock exchange but you all
have question cards so we're going to
keep the lights up a little bit higher
than normal in the beginning the brevity
and clarity of your questions will
really and be a major factor of whether
or not they get asked because they have
to be read by Kevin Kelly up here in the
front and then I have to read them up
onstage in front of you all while also
having a conversation so short and well
and very clearly written is helpful so
way back in 1996 when the long now
foundation was started one of the main
driving factors that was that was being
talked about was the the kind of next
quarter economics of all companies and
and you can imagine back then there was
the time where and speed was being
fetishized
above all else and it wasn't until the
bubble burst that people started
thinking a little bit differently about
that but I thought what was really
interesting is that when Jeff Bezos
launched Amazon in 1997 as a public
company he he published a letter
alongside the the offering and it was
entitled it's all about the long term
and I think what's interesting is what
he was saying then is that if everything
you do is work on a three year time
horizon then you're competing against a
lot of people but if you're willing to
invest on a seven year time horizon
you're now competing against a fraction
of those people because very few
companies actually do that so just by
lengthening the time horizon you engage
in endeavors that you could never
otherwise do and that's really what
after Eric had been spent has been a lot
of time
in a way kind of shortening that the
development cycles of companies but as
he did that he saw that where the value
was going on was not really getting
pushed further out and at the very end
of this book which there's pre signed
copies out in the lobby this was really
the idea that he ended which with which
was the long-term stock exchange and so
tonight he and I are going to talk about
that please
don't trip on the fire yeah that should
have been the special thank you hi
everybody thank you for coming Wow cool
yeah so I think I'd love to just start
with that I mean you you kinda you
finished this book that was the Lean
Startup and it was so much of it is
about how to make your company get to
good ideas faster yeah and but at the
very end of it you say you know what we
really need to do is create a system of
a socket change that that is more about
valuing less about speed in a way yeah
it's actually a really interesting
paradox in a corporate setting that took
me by surprise is you know who picked
the book I got to see this up close and
personal and so many different kinds of
companies that I always assumed you know
as a civilian that the shorter the
accountability time horizon the faster
everything would go so if companies are
like rigorously operating by the quarter
then there must be really fast because
you can't get very much done in three
months so you better go fast but
actually it's an inverse correlation the
companies that actually operate on very
rapid product development cycles the
ones that are more scientific more
iterative in their approach and this is
true of Amazon's true of if you studied
like Toyota Production system are the
ones that have that long term philosophy
that is the support layer that people
need to do this no more scientific type
of inquiry where each experiment needs
to happen quickly so that we get to the
overall thesis over the long term like
before we're all dead and I couldn't
figure out why it was like a paradox it
was very evident if you I mean how many
of you have ever talked to a middle
manager public company ever if you have
then you've already heard them moan and
groan about how awful it is to be under
this quarterly pressure and all the bad
stuff and we'll get to that I'm sure but
eventually I realized what was going on
is that if you're a quarterly cadence
type company there's actually two kinds
of projects that you have to run from
time to time there are projects which
can reasonably be completed in one
quarter and for that you have this
extremely rigorous forecasting and
accountability system and you know who's
doing a good job not that's category one
projects and then you have the other
category which I just call other then
there's other projects that don't work
so you're like I want to do something
over the course of one year or god
forbid three years or
for Jeff like for seven years it's like
well that better go on the other bucket
and so how is the other bucket
adjudicated
no one knows there's no system or rigor
to that bug it's just like well Ash's
politics if I can unlock some money I
can get this project and of course
middle managers since time immemorial
have figured out that if you can get
yourself promoted to a different job
before the expected launch date of the
thing that you can never fail and it's
funny because you know none of you I
understand would ever pull this trick
but you know this is going on in
corporations when I give talks about
Lean Startup in corporate context and I
start talking about that everyone looks
around to be like is it okay to laugh at
this joke because we all know this is
going on there are in fact executives
today who have played that trick their
whole career I've never launched
anything and actually from an ROI point
of view they're being very rational
that's probably the best way to be
promoted because reality will never
impinge on the story that you tell about
what a great visionary person you are we
do that a little bit in Silicon Valley
too so so yeah so like that paradox
really surprised me in the research even
leading up to writing the Lean Startup
and then as I've gotten to see it up
close it's been it's been really
shocking and it doesn't really make
sense this is like the main takeaway for
me we've gotten used to this just
everyone's like well yeah you have to
hold people accountable yeah it should
be on a quote like we just we've autumn
use to it so if you ask why does it
matter that a sale was completed on
December 31st versus January first is
that is that important in any way to the
long-term health of the corporation most
people would say yeah you you made the
deadline it helped the numbers for the
quarter but if you really like think of
like doesn't make any sense at all when
did this become an idea that we accepted
and then when we started to build
people's incentive systems to drive
certain outcomes like basically running
the corporation for the sake of the
report then it's just like in sports or
any other situation where like now
people like the company's being run for
the report the report is not useful
anymore it was really useful when it was
a random sample of like what's happening
in the corporation doing that four times
you're sure we got a sample at some
frequency why not
but now that we're running corporations
to produce beautiful reports then aid
the reports are not accurate anymore no
no investors actually really believe the
information in these reports anymore but
also we're having thousands of people
tens of thousands of people contort
their lives to produce these outcomes in
these reports why and that because I
came at this from the outside I'm just a
computer software programmer
you know and I became this public figure
through the writing of this book but I
didn't I just never imagined it would
lead to anything remotely like this so I
go in these I've been in these
boardrooms and in factory floors and in
with middle managers of every level all
up and down the stack companies that are
five years old and a hundred years old
and longer we were talking about and
governments and agencies and and
everywhere you go this is just the
accepted reality it and if you ask
people what are the top problems
afflicting your organization people will
vent to you about this as like the most
destructive problem and then if you say
why is it that way what can we do about
it they give you this look you should
try this really fun they will give you
this look that's like you said what
should we do about gravity you don't do
anything about gravity it just is that's
the way that it do weak we've taken this
whole system as this this is the way
that it is like gravity but it's not it
we made the system and we could make it
any way that we see fit and I mean we
were talking a little bit about this
before but it reminds me of that time
when the music industry saw all of their
profits falling through the floor and if
you talk to any person at any level of
the music industry they all knew that
selling music on plastic circles was not
a viable business model anymore but it
was like it was similar was like gravity
like what are we gonna do and and you
know what to do go I mean I walked a
factory floor of any organization you go
to the lowest level that people that
work for a living those people know what
to do like a huge part of lean startup
and the transformation of organizations
has been simply harnessing the good
ideas that are already there most
organizations operate at tremendous
a creativity dampening field which is on
to prevent anybody from having any
creative ideas or expressing them it's
really expensive to operate this thing
but if you build a management system
that is based on the eradication of
variation and variance then creativity
and innovation are your enemy not your
ally and so we we do this work we ain't
this men and I work with a lot of
executives over the years and I tell
them listen this might sound like your a
criticism so I get that you're pissed at
me right now for telling you this
information but it's actually really
good news to get more creativity and
more innovation all the good things that
you want in your organization you don't
have to go out and buy a bunch of
startups you don't to go get more fancy
Oakridge it just turn the dampening
field off for like a day see what
happens you might be surprised and you
know that that's a huge part of my work
with organizations is to get them just
to experiment with the possibility of
unlocking the full human potential of
the people that work there it's like a
vast untapped resource
so the learned helplessness and this
kind of like idea that this is just how
it is and there's nothing you can do
about it and yeah we the boss wants me
to behave this way like there's just a
really deeply fatalistic and pessimistic
view of what is possible in the heart of
business especially where we're supposed
to be the can-do optimistic changed the
world
you know rah rah and I I just think it's
really it's really bad I mean it reminds
me of what of what Steve Jobs had to do
even with his own cut within his own
company in order to finish the Mac right
he had to like take his engineers take
them out of the building put the rent a
new space fly a skull and crossbones
flag but literally up the flagpole and
in order to to get that creativity
dampening field kind of released in
order to get him through the project
yeah yeah middle managers are like ninja
assassins they will find you and kill
you so you gotta if you want to have
innovation in your organization you do
have to solve that problem but it is
solvable it's not like some dark art can
be solved the middle managers are human
beings they're behaving rationally and
responding to incentives like we all do
right and then so let's let's take a
step back here and can you tell us how
stock exchanges work sure how much how
much time you have
it's funny you know it wasn't that long
ago that stock exchanges were
not-for-profit entities and now there
are for-profit companies mine too so
that's just how it is now and and when I
was talking to regulators and
policymakers about our exchange I
floated the idea that it should be a
non-profit it was like people were
aghast at this old-fashioned idea and I
was told on knows uncertain terms that
that would not be permitted under any
circumstances this is actually illegal
or do you just wasn't gonna happen
there's not really a distinction between
those two things like you think there is
if you wanted to like I it's it's a very
complicated thing the way our regulatory
apparatus works and if you think about
it it may it's actually a really
difficult problem they're trying to
solve like technocratic governance
requires independent agencies
independent of what politics independent
of you and me independent of the
citizenry is citizens ability to exert
their democratic influence over the
process so that's actually really tough
balancing act to have a democracy that
is responsive to the will of the people
but also not responsive to the world of
people and so well what is legal and not
legal in such a system is quite quite
complicated so yeah I was I was told
that not to pursue that so stock
exchanges what are they why don't we
have them in the old days like here's
what people think stock exchanges are in
the old days we wanted to have people be
able to buy and sell the stocks of
corporations so you could save for your
retirement and so that was logistically
extremely difficult and it needed to
happen in a specific place because stock
certificates were actual pieces of paper
and filing cabinets and when you wanted
to buy one somebody had to go find the
certificate for the buyer and move it to
the site actually move it around so like
even today a lot of the way the system
is built is around this like now all
trading is electronic but settlement
still takes three business days to
change a bit in a database from this
person's name for that person's name but
its rules were built at a time when that
was actually a difficult thing to do so
in those days stock exchanges were
physical places where brokers did these
transactions on behalf of their clients
and you had to be a member
the exchange and if you've ever seen
pictures of the old New York Stock
Exchange they had the up people who got
to be upstairs and the people downstairs
in the pit and was a it was in economic
turns out terms a it's a called
supply-side increasing returns and
demand side increasing returns network
effects type business you want it to be
the place where the most stocks were
when you're trading and companies wanted
to be listed in the place where they
would be the most brokers and therefore
the most liquidity so they were
extremely rigorous network type
marketplaces this and if you go actually
if you ever get a chance to go visit the
New York Stock Exchange the marble
building in New York that the servers
are in New Jersey now so there's no
exchanging happening in that building
anymore but it's a beautiful Museum and
they actually have the original
agreement that they worked out that
what's called a Buttonwood tree
agreement if you read it closely it's a
price-fixing agreement that fix the
Commission's that all brokers would
charge and the idea that if you
controlled the brokerage of these
transactions you had this enormous power
such that you could set control prices
and do all these other things like that
was a really breakthrough idea and it it
had it's good things and it's bad things
anyway that's what a stock exchange used
to be but everything I just said is
really not relevant anymore because now
trading is electronic and when trading
when electronic I know how much history
you really want here but when trading
when electronic the exchanges refused to
pass the savings of electronic trading
on to the public so all of a sudden got
dramatically cheaper to run a stock
exchange and prices stayed the same
and the SEC didn't like that and there
was a lot of wrangling among the brokers
and who got the fees and whatever and
exchanges were converted to for-profit
corporations and then the SEC in order
to promote competition among the
exchanges introduced what's called the
national market system so although there
are multiple stock exchanges in America
there is only one national market system
and the national market system means
that every exchange trades every other
exchanges stocks so your image you have
of demand-side and supplies increasing
returns all over that's not true anymore
when companies list on any exchange it's
like a portal into this vast pool of
liquidity that is shared across all
American investors and brokers anyone
can trade in and out the servers are all
in New Jersey they're not just in future
in general but they're in a very
specific location in New Jersey because
the system was not designed by software
engineers but by lawyers and they
decided in all their ways to use a
physical network to determine the
dissemination of information from point
A to point B and any of you who've taken
an entering class or remember that that
software information does not move
instantaneously but rather at the speed
of light and therefore whichever server
is closest to the source of truth an
exchange gets the information slightly
faster than the other service so
literally every cage in the data center
where these servers are is more
expensive if you're closer to the center
then if you're further away and god
forbid you're in Chicago or something
you know it's by foot closer oh we're
talking about like literally the
physical space that the Cable has to has
to travel and so the other issue is that
the national market system also has this
idea that if you're just a regular
person and you want to buy stock on the
exchange you can just say I would like
to have the best price so I'll just take
whatever the best price is right now and
if you make an order of that type it has
to be routed whoever has the best price
right now did anyone catch the problem
what is right now me because you guys
studied relativity right you understand
there is no such thing as right now
there's only the information that I can
perceive in my place as it travels a
distance to me from the other places and
there are 15 places where this trend
these transactions happen 15 exchanges
15 exchanges and so people figured out
that wait a minute
if I have the fastest connection of
anybody I can like simultaneously place
and cancel orders at these 15 venues
faster than anybody else can and I can
get an advantage from doing that and
other people said why should compete
with that guy I've got the faster
connect I'll get an even faster
connection and then we had the credible
arms race of people trying to get faster
and faster and faster and faster
connections but this arms race cannot go
on indefinitely because the speed of
light is fixed and the competition is
running asymptotically up against the
wall of the speed of light so it's a
totally a valueless zero-sum game like
activity this is what's driving most
stock exchange transactions there are
now more transactions ever than in
history the volume has traded on
exchanges is
is massive and I haven't even gotten
into the dark pools and the other
affiliated transaction infrastructure
because you only asked about exchanges
good anyway that's that's what they do
if you're a company who wants to list on
exchange you might ask what value do I
get from all these millions and millions
of transactions happening driving my
stock all over the place not related to
my fundamentals and the answer is none
it's actively harmful to your ability to
run your business and then you'd be like
well cool I guess that's just how it is
because you have to be listed on the
stock exchange might be a public company
and until now there have only ever been
two companies that run the two places
where companies can list nicey and
Nasdaq and that really hasn't been the
creation of a new model for how
companies could be listed since the
creation of Nasdaq which was in the 60s
so it's kind of a mess this is a short
version right and so I think you I mean
you said a very interesting thing at the
beginning when about what stock
exchanges are which is that they were a
place to invest in companies where you
believed in their product
yeah and largely over the your own whole
lifetime like it was for your retirement
people that's a retirement or the
ultimate long-term investors people
wanted something that was an investment
that was 20 to 50 year investment yet
now almost all trades are happening by
milliseconds so who's making the
decisions at the millisecond level
yeah the average holding period for a
lot of equity of public equity trading
shops is 10 minutes so nothing happens
in 10 minutes
to a multinational corporation nothing
had literally nothing happens so it's
it's a bit of a mess and at the speed of
these transactions are being made humans
can no longer participate as brokers so
there really aren't human stockbrokers
anymore in the way that we previously
would have understood
we now have algorithms that act on
behalf of brokers and the trend in
investing is towards what's called
passive investing I'm sure you all know
most people are putting their money into
passively held funds that just buy the
whole market or an entire index but then
there's this question of which index
should you use and there's now a
proliferation of index providers that
wait the stocks slightly differently or
have different criteria for inclusion or
exclusion and it's like this is the new
active investing is which index you
follow but indexing only works if
somebody is setting the price that we
all follow I mean I lose my
money's in passive investments dude
we're all we're all in passive
investments as to trend but we're free
riding off the price discovery of a
shrinking percentage of the market
because more and more and more dollars
I'm moving into passive investing and
the price discovery that's happening in
the active part of the market is being
done by computers that are trying to get
a trading edge against the other
computers that are trying to trade and
at some point you got to ask if this
trend continues and all humans have
their money in passive funds see where
this is going few people are laughing
already
and and Anna dwindling for Senator and
these active funds that are all being
run by computers who is actually setting
the price and is that setting the price
be it will it be in any way related to
the fundamental activity of the company
so is it possible that that you could
eventually lead to a world where there
will be no correlation whatsoever
between the price that a stock trades at
any given time and the underlying
fundamental value of the company and I
don't really know what the plan is like
maybe that won't happen for some reason
but all the trends are pointing in that
direction and therefore we're all opting
out have you noticed the total number of
companies that are listed on public
exchanges in the United States is
shrinking it's done 50 percent 50
percent in the last 20 years is the most
remarkable graph in capitalism I think
because a lots happened the last 20
years you guys have noticed remember
we've had booms and busts and we've seen
it all here right the graph is just
straight down you cannot see the dot-com
bubble on this graph you cannot see the
Great Recession on this graph it's just
every year attrition of the total number
of companies from about 10,000 to about
5,000 and there's no it has no sign of
abating we could only gets offset
because well knows you get international
listings but if you look at American
companies it's straight to the floor so
the next generation of companies that in
any other era would be public companies
have just opted out of the system and
said well why would we want to be listed
on this crazy casino what do we get out
of it and it used the answers to be you
could raise large amounts of money if
you did this but now you can raise
plenty of money while you're a private
so what do you need to do why why do you
why do I really be public now I think
there are benefits but in order for
companies to reap the benefits we have
to deal now with the kind of layering
protections around them
all this other noise noise and nonsense
and as a result the public is getting
screwed none of us except those of us
were accredited investors but most of
the public is not allowed by law to
invest in growth companies and then
economists have started to notice
something they call secular stagnation
which is that there's not a lot of
growth happening in the public markets
and in people's retirement savings and
this is like a big conundrum of why is
this happening but one of the reasons
happening is because of growth companies
are just are opting out of being in your
portfolio and they're still able to
raise plenty of money from oligarchs and
sovereign wealth funds and all kinds of
folks so like they're doing okay and
people talk about this like it's a real
act of greed on behalf of these startup
founders you know depriving the public
of the whatever but think how crazy this
has become in a lot of cases like if you
have a multi billion dollar private
company you're the founder of you want a
significant percentage of it so you
stand to make hundreds of millions of
dollars or even billions of dollars in
some cases personally of liquid net
worth from taking your company public
and you're putting it off who among us
would have the courage the strength to
put it off and could we call that an act
of greed you know it's something else
and as a result if we don't fix this
problem the backlash that we're starting
to get the taste of now is gonna get
dramatically worse because people out
there buy I talk to a lot of people in
the valley now who are like people keep
saying we've been like left out left
behind what are they talking about
well why are they so mad but they've
been literally left like they are not
allowed to invest in our companies
anymore we've like fundamentally broken
the connection between investment in
innovation in R&D in the future and the
broad public's desire to reap the
benefits of disruption it's like the
creative destruction of the economy that
we laud as capitalists you know that
comes with costs and one of the ways
those costs get offset is the public
benefits from the economic activity that
we generate and when you talk to
founders and people who live through the
earlier cycles of entrepreneurship in
this country in a Steve Case told me the
story about founding AOL took AOL public
and I can't remember now I think AOL ray
remember the number I think $75,000,000
when it went public yeah people who are
in the business start laughing I POS
used to be really small he sued them
Remy early Amazon I think what public
after three years of operation now
he said people still to this day stop
him on the street and say thank you for
putting my kids through college because
if you had the fortitude now you
would've had some courage to do this you
had the fortitude to by AOL at the IPO
and just hold it through that crazy run
up and had hopefully you sold at the top
that was an incredible amount of growth
that was available to ordinary people
and no founders that I know in this
generation have that experience no one
feels that way it's not it's only VCS
and and a very few select investment
funds who are reaping those rewards and
sad and so now tell us how you're fixing
goal what is the long term oh oh did I
sorry no I
there's no good news so the long-term
stock exchange fundamentally is a
different idea on stock exchanges yeah
so so we had this idea and I wrote about
it in the book so if you if you grab
your old battered copy of the Lean
Startup and you turn to the very last
page you will see this idea listed not
as something that I should have to do by
the way something that somebody should
do that's by just an aside the very best
part of being an author is you get to
have a whole chapter at the end we just
say that these are things that somebody
should really get on doing and you're
done you've published a book and there's
like people do the things and the book
became a phenomenon and it used if you
study this book almost every ludicrous
thing that I suggested that somebody
should do someone has actually tried in
the intervening years some of them
turned out to be great ideas others
that's good but people tried them with
one exception there's one idea that no
one ever called me even one time to say
is is that one still available could I
do the stock exchange one never got
asked and the idea is is very polarizing
I remember just an aside I in the
manuscript for Lean Startup I obviously
did a lot of testing with customers for
the Lean Startup
otherwise I would be accused of being a
hypocrite so I did a ton of there were
test readers and a/b tests and a lot of
testing and experimentation and one of
these we did we sent it out a near final
manuscript to a number of tests
readers in the industry and kind of
prominent people and ask them just what
you read and give us your feedback and
one person wrote me back he said this
book is great I really like it with one
exception on page 399 you have this idea
that is so stupid
you in one page you flush away all of
the credibility you have painstakingly
built up over the previous however many
hundreds of pages and you must take it
out so it was kind of like that for a
lot of years of people saying this is
this is really a terrible idea was
really polarizing and what people don't
realize now is that that's how people
responded to Lean Startup in the early
days now it's considered like accepted
wisdom and I'm very honored that people
feel so good like but now it's
considered almost like duh obviously and
like the kids coming out of Stanford and
Berkeley doing startups now they're like
can't believe that somebody had to write
a book about it like it's so obvious and
then they're like they can't believe
that it was there like I thought it was
written in that 80s or something you
know what yeah I thought you'd be old
and I'm like this was what came out in
2011 it's not even ten years old give me
a break and so I mean I know that's
wonderful I'm so glad that people found
the ideas and it's gone well but this
idea just has driven me crazy this whole
time I put in the blog was like the fact
that people reacted in that way it was
so polarizing it that was a good sign to
me like wow I'm on to something this
must be interesting let's see what
happens we put out in Tulsa fo says if
you're if you're not getting flak you're
not over the target yeah like that code
a lot yeah that's been the last ten
years of my life a hundred percent and
so the idea of the book was just like
this people who run companies say that
if you ask them like why do you run
quarter-to-quarter why do you distract
your employees with this nonsense like
why do you short-term compensation
instruments that cause people to
optimize for these local results instead
of the global maximum they said well us
what Wall Street wants and I never made
sense to me
I was like wait you're telling me that
your own investors want your company to
be worth less money because it's
distracted from its fundamental mission
of serving customers and they're like
yeah like if you really ask them like I
don't need to ask them my other sticker
right here it tells me in real time
exactly what they want at all times
and I was like that's that's like asking
they've I had a heart rate monitor of
somebody and I'm like now I know exactly
what they wanted all times right now
it's not exactly the same was
understanding what they genuinely truly
want so I was like well let me talk to
some investors and understand this can't
be right there must be a mistake and of
course if you talk to people who are
actually long-term investors they're
like oh you think I'm the source of
short-termism screw you like let me tell
you about the short-term venture
capitalist and he's greedy founders and
Silicon Valley managers calling me
short-term no they're the ones who were
short-term and I would take that back to
doodle really come back Silicon Valley
like I heard that we're the ones who
were short term like no they're the ones
who are short term we're going like this
everyone thinks somebody else is the one
that's causing the short termism and I
had this epiphany I was literally
sitting at an airplane flying to some
speech about Lean Startup in 2010
reading a book about Jeff Bezos or
probably Toyota Production system
something like that the literature by
the way the research on what creates
outstanding companies what really
creates out something organizations
it's unequivocally clear that having a
philosophy of long term thinking is a
prerequisite for doing anything good
this shows up in the data the research
madonnas is really good and I was like
well how can that be right
that the very thing that we know for
sure is what's needed to build great
companies is antithetical to the
economic environment that we're taking
companies into you know all of us
Silicon Valley we're all trying to build
public companies we're all trying to
sell our companies to public companies
while trying to make ourselves subject
to these short-term pressure which makes
our companies less valuable which means
investors lose money and I was like I
thought we were I thought it's a
capitalist system I thought were
for-profit companies so how can this be
right so I didn't every sense to me and
I finally was like aha it just have a
little in an airplane and it came to me
I said what we need is a way for those
companies which actually are long-term
and those investors that are actually
long-term to come together for mutual
benefit and we'll just build our own
market with our own social contract that
says we're gonna actually run things for
long term and we don't need to be
activists about it we don't need to get
me to run for president anything just
it's a for-profit company these they're
all former other companies well we will
actually make more money if companies
perform better which I did not really
expect to be controversial it seemed
like I thought I was making a QED like
straightforward deduction from the first
principles of like what is capitalism to
whatever I didn't even know what a stock
exchange was yet see I told
all about stop I didn't know the one
thing about stock exchanges I was just
sitting I was literally sitting there
and being like you know what I need from
first principles I need an institution
that can regulate the behavior of
investors and managers at the same time
so you invented a stock exchange on that
airplane yeah I was like I know we
should make a stock exchange and I just
wrote in them just I was sitting there
with my could be with my manuscript
right here have it open I'll just throw
it in here and see what happens why not
I if you had told me that day that this
would be a controversial idea to anybody
I would have been shocked and that was
it that was the idea and you know pretty
easy idea to say took three paragraphs
in the book to write it's not as easy of
an idea to build so I spent years just I
can't even describe this to you like
this is the first thing in my life where
I feel like I didn't my subjective
experiences I did not have this idea my
life was really good before I had this
idea I did I did not need this idea
honestly my experience with this idea
had me it came to me this I wrote it in
the thing and I was like good my work
here is done
I wrote it I'm an author now not an
entrepreneur I wrote it in the book I
did my responsibility I put it out into
the world and now this problem will
solve itself and I can go on with my
life and this is when he would not leave
me alone will I keep me up at night it
would bother me all the time as I would
go around in the world and as the book
became a phenomenon and I got to go work
with companies I mean you name an order
of magnitude of companies from two
founders in a garage up to the world's
biggest multinationals and every order
magnet in between I've had the chance to
work with companies of that size and I
can now I can pretty much win a bingo
contest where you'd give me like sector
or industry of the company and size and
I'll be like oh yeah there's an example
oh yeah here's an example and now you
could cross that with corporate function
I can tell you a story about people in
that industry at that size and that
function how they were grappling with
with lean start so I got this really
wide education and yet everywhere you go
this is the problem people complained to
you about you can't you can't avoid it
and once you've had this idea I just
like why is it such a bad idea I don't
understand and so I started to talk to
people about it and I I spent years just
asking everyone I knew you don't know
any investors know anybody that knows
anything about Wall Street
what is Wall Street how do you go there
is it a place is a thing what was a
state of mind what is it how do I learn
more about it and I asked VC's do who
don't
public market people and people I made
the intros and I would have these
conversations big high on this kid from
Silicon Valley and I've got this idea
you tell me all the reasons why it's
terrible and they'd be like no problem
first it violates the efficient market
hypothesis second you know brokers will
never go for it third it's antisocial
and it will lead to communism fourth you
name it I swear to god I have a burden
over the years and what was so and I was
just I was like delighted I was like
great one day someone will sit me down
and explain to me why this is a bad idea
and it will leave me alone and the
problem was people's reasons for why it
was a bad idea it made no sense it
wasn't that like they were not
persuasive because they were almost all
variations of like kid I am making so
much money from things the way it is
exactly right now could you please go
away and leave me alone
people wouldn't say it exactly that way
but I started to learn that was like
this doesn't make sense nobody can
answer the question for me why like I
was like I have very simple questions
why do we report quarterly why are
companies allowed to give guidance I
don't understand meanwhile I'm working
with companies every day we're at the
first sign of trouble if the guidance is
off if the court is not going well the
very first thing they do is cancel the
innovation projects you all lifted this
you know what I'm talking about
we literally eat the seed corn as like a
best practice why so if you ask me why
do you do this it doesn't make second
answer these questions it wasn't like
they had a really good answer and that
just was like I would like I want to
make you a little bit better it's like
you will be like I don't know it's just
how it is it's just gravity right just
this is just how it and so I started to
ask people well how do you build the new
stock exchange I have this idea for a
new stock exchange I'd like to build a
new one and when you I told you that
look people get on your face try this
one it's like you're saying I'd like to
make a new moon and this like it's a
weird question because like hey we
already have one it's fine we don't need
another one but also that's not a human
thing to do you don't make a moon it's
just it's in the sky it's a thing and
people have this image the beautiful
marble building with the bull we're
gonna have another bull it's what what
animal is your it's gonna have I mean
I've been I've her dog so eventually I
got to a moment where I met a securities
lawyer and the other problem is most
people who are experts in this topic
make a lot of money from the status quo
so they won't help you but I finally
found someone who's like at the perfect
borderline of just inside enough to know
the
answers to my questions but not making
so much money they was not invested in
reform and I said to him how do you make
a new stock exchange he said oh it's not
that hard that was gone was like oh
really is that you just fill out form
one and I didn't card tune we did a
double-take we're like I'm sorry well I
can't what he's like yeah it's for its
called you did follow a form one
application it's literally form one and
I was like I could understand him he's
like listen you understand how
government forms are all numbered uh-huh
this is SEC form number zero zero one
the application to establish a national
securities exchange it's a frickin form
and I was just like you're kidding me
now it's like listen it's 200 pages long
and the most important thing about the
talking about I need to have a legal
memo written to explain why I wanted to
go talk to guests about it's like when
you go to meet the SEC the most
important thing about your legal memo is
anyone want to guess I was like oh the
structure of my argument the precedent
that I can cite into whatever I'm very
earnest good student right it's like no
it's whose letterhead it will be lit and
written on what lawyer will write this
letter for you I was like who cares it's
on the American wages like kid listen
there's only three lawyers who are
really qualified for this it needs to be
on one of their letterhead and I'm like
oh man and then I said wait can I meet
these people I can meet it's like oh
sure yeah introduce you it was like all
these problems seemed like totally
intractable and then and this just has
been almost 10 years now of like one
foot in front of the other one step one
little experiment and so it's like yeah
you fill out the form it has a lot of
parts you have to hire a bunch of people
you have to raise a lot of money you
have to have the right lobbyists you
have to have the right lawyers you have
to learn all this jargon in this
impenetrable whatever to learn how
Washington DC actually works but ok it
was like each step didn't seem that hard
and I was like well I'll just take this
one step and see what happens and I was
expecting for most of the first five
years of this that I would take a few
steps I would eventually meet the one
person that I finally meet the man
behind the curtain
and he'd be like oh kid you made it
behind the curtain let me now explain to
you why this can never work
and it will leave you alone and I should
go back to my nuts like that because
turns would screw up gravity for right
it's like the problem with the tides and
people would die and act like oh my god
this thing and so but there's there's 15
exchanges in the world yeah but they're
in the US yeah in the US sorry yeah and
so but most most things happen on a few
exchanges and most of the even yeah yeah
it's a very misleading statistic because
there are 15 exchanges there actually 15
medallions as if they were taxi
medallions that's what they call them in
DC there are 15 exchange medallions but
there are only five companies that
operate stock exchanges in the US and
three of us only have one medallion each
so do the math why do two of the
companies have 12 medallions between
them turns out that they get they get
rents for the more medallions they have
in there these committees that control
the governance of our capital markets
and the more medallions you have the
more votes you get just like texting
guns just saying I'm just saying so yeah
the vast majority and they don't think
that's the other change that we haven't
talked about is in the last 20 years
more and more trading has moved off the
exchanges themselves so the vast
majority of trading now doesn't even
happen on the stock exchange it happens
either in a dark pool or through what's
called internalization which is a great
euphemism for you make a transaction and
your broker never trades it with anybody
they just trade it themselves at what
they consider to be the best price so if
you trade for free on a stock trading
app or something you don't pay any
Commission's and you've ever wondered
like how come I get to do this for free
they this is not I'm not revealing I'm
not breaking news here these are all in
public filings you can go read about
exactly every company that trades stocks
they have to disclose exactly where the
Troc stocks are traded and they get paid
to send their orders to this person and
not to that person so it's called
payment for order flow and it governs
how all the transactions actually are
running through through the exchanges so
the vast majority not only of exchanges
but of financial institutions at all in
this country make their money through
transactions and transaction fees and
the associated rents that you can
extract from transaction flow so like
transactions rule everything
in corporate listings that's the process
of taking your company and listing it on
a stock exchange there are only really
two players
there's NASDAQ and the New York Stock
Exchange they have 99.999% of the market
the only exception is bats which is one
of the other exchanges which is listed
on bats so all other companies the
companies you've all heard of are all
listed at those two two venues and their
rules of what the listing standards of
how the how companies should be governed
are almost indistinguishable rulesets
they're very very very similar if they
were here they would say that one is
better than the other you understand but
fundamentally if you talk to companies
and you ask them I did this for a lot of
years hey how did you choose which
exchange to list your company on I want
to guess the most common answer the CEO
always wanted to ring the bell on CNBC
or we thought I'd be cooler to have a
party in Times Square so we picked the
other one for a number of years Nasdaq
was running a promotion where you got
free facebook ad credits to use in the
holiday season if you listed on NASDAQ
site the ultimate free toaster this is
these are commodified businesses
offering a commodity product with the
incredibly strong duopoly such a strong
duopoly that it's suicide of course to
attempt to crack this duopoly over open
but i didn't know any better so so we
just went ahead so so yeah we built a
team we first raise money for the
company in 2015 we started the process
of working with the SEC in 2016 we got
our form one application approved last
May so thank you thank you
yeah that's how I feel about it too and
we are America's newest Stock Exchange
and I know this is a little bit of a
complicated question of look but when
when do we get to see you on the market
yeah
so we have acquired the world's most
expensive taxi medallion but we are not
yet driving the car around do they send
you a real thing no there's no you don't
get a I got I got a cooler a shinier
membership card from you guys and I got
from the SEC you just get the psychic
satisfaction of knowing that you're now
subject to the one of the most stringent
regulatory regimes that any business can
be subject to for a good reason because
you get a grant of sovereign power from
the United States federal government you
have to treat it very seriously and we
do we will be opening the exchange over
the course of this year I can't say
exactly when cuz it it's not actually
the kind of thing that you launch like
on a certain day there's a whole series
of boot up operations that happen but we
will start trading trading stocks no no
earlier than q2 of this year and then
we'll be open to be able to solicit
companies to list on the exchange
because another really funny quirk of
stock exchanges is that all this time
the only question anyone really wants
know the answer to is who will list who
will abide by these higher standards who
will truly first to take the plunge to
say like we will lead the industry into
a brave new world of responsibility and
long term thinking and technically
speaking I'm not allowed to solicit
anybody to list on the exchange because
it doesn't operate so I have a large
number of informational meetings with
these founders and CEOs and executives
of this next generation of companies and
so that the process of solicitation can
begin later in the year and you know
will take some time obviously because
not like you just show up you're like hi
I think you should do your IPO in my
exchange and they'll be like oh great
let's do it next Tuesday it takes it
takes some time so I watch it all happen
that should all begin that process it'll
happen this year oh I want to back up
just a little bit because I do want to
talk about it I know that you can't talk
about the companies that are that
maillist yeah you can talk a little bit
about the categories of them sure which
I do want to do but I want to say like
what is what is your innovation here
like what do you for what is have you
turned off gravity and built a new moon
yeah yeah and now now all the companies
are interested in the long term like
what is what does a company have to do
differently to list with you versus the
yeah now stack or something yeah so the
big difference with us and the incumbent
exchanges is we are principals driven
not rules driven so what I've learned
doing lean startup especially is like if
you make anything a rule
like I check the box exercises companies
are really good at checking boxes and
they will check they will do whatever is
needed to check the box if they think
there's any advantage to them to do that
and since this is not really about
checking the box this is about the
mindset and the incentives that drive
the corporation we had to do something a
little bit more powerful so embedded in
our listing standards are a set of
principles that companies have to sign
up to but as soon as I say that you're
like oh god another pledge all right
come on admit it you were thinking it
it's okay they're all these pledges but
companies have designed all these
pledges lately it's we're in pledged
season practically and and they're all
like we're gonna be multi-stakeholder
we're gonna be this we're gonna be that
we're gonna be really good we're gonna
be good citizens if you asked like okay
but why should we believe that you will
actually do the things that the pledge
requires it was actually this like a
running joke I think in a TV show
Silicon Valley where the guys like no
you don't understand this it has no
binding commitment it cost you nothing
why don't you not signing it the other
guys like what why but then why should I
sign anything but why shouldn't you sign
it and so like if you can be parodied in
a TV show like maybe we could do better
than that so our idea is that for each
principle it's like for example that
company should be multi-stakeholder that
they should plot their time horizon in
years and decades not quarters that they
should incentivize their boards and
their employees for the long term
that they should treat their long-term
investors like the citizens of the
Republic different from the tourists so
for each principle we require companies
to create an operating policy that is
responsive to that principle and we
actually allow a lessor that has to be
an independently verifiable series of
actions otherwise we're Stock Exchange
we can't enforce it so yes you have to
make changes to your Charter to your
bylaws that you like and this is like
really in the weeds but like the charter
of the Governance Committee what does it
say the charter of the comp committee
what does it say and the acid test for
me and one of these policies is like the
true test of a corporation of corporate
governance to me is god forbid if it's
discovered one day that your product is
toxic or dangerous or unhealthy for your
own customers or the societies and
communities that they inhabit is there
anybody in your corporation who has a
fiduciary duty to care
or are they more likely gonna sweep it
under the rug thank you right yeah isn't
it that simple how many companies have
failed that test in recent years look
around you know so we have not done well
in this score compared that to like when
Johnson and Johnson had tylenol be
suspected of having poison in one of the
tile member that story it's now taught
in business schools a case study of what
to do the voluntary nationwide recall in
during incredible short-term pain for
the unbelievable long-term game of
winning the public's trust so we try to
create structures in each company and we
also sell them software and services to
help them abide by these by these
policies so that's I'm not this is not a
non-profit I said that at the beginning
but our idea is that for each pile each
principle we can help them actually make
structural changes structural reforms
that align the incentives of everybody
in the corporation around a long-term
multi-stakeholder view and in order to
listen our exchange you have to make a
binding commitment to those principles
by making public what your operating
policy will be that is responsive to it
and then we enforce this is the other
critical thing the reason we went
through all the pain and difficulty of
becoming a stock exchange is that in our
modern economy corporations can pretty
much only commit one crime and that's
securities fraud there are no other
crimes every other crime is adjudicated
through security sparked if you notice
this like there's bribery scandal like
what actually gets them its securities
fraud it's like component of taxes so
the most important thing if you want a
company to take something seriously is
make sure that not doing it would cause
them to commit securities from so by
forcing them to make these commitments
public by enforcing them through the
listing standards of the exchange
there's actual real enforcement if they
don't do it and I don't think there's
anything like that that exists today so
our view is is like a genuinely new
approach to corporate governance that is
aligned with what this next generation
of companies and their employees and
their investors really want that's
really awesome look at their what a
great guy
right what is it wouldn't you like your
company to have that corporate
governance model yeah actually I see by
a show of hands how many of you are in
the tech sector who work here all right
okay so everybody for the packs a lot of
people company how many is not how many
of you are not in the tech sector okay
least one artist in the crowd whereas if
jazz for God's sake and so what is the
risk of a company so low I mean let's
say if I'm a I'm two guys in a garage
and I'm thinking about going public or
let's say I'm I'm I'm Amazon like and I
want to participate in this way what do
I need to do can i list on more than one
exchange or the limits to that why would
I do one versus the other yeah so we do
allow dual listing this is very
important if you've always had the dream
of one day taking you're going to ring
the bell at an NYC
god bless far be it for me to get in the
way of that okay we don't even want to
be what's called the primary exchange
that oh does the open and closing
auction every day of your stock because
that's a huge subsidy that the exchanges
get for those transactions you have a
monopoly but we're happy to be the
secondary exchange because we don't care
about trading volume and we're not gonna
compete for trading volume and we refuse
to play any of the high frequency
trading games and all that stuff that I
was talking about before obviously we
put it right in the name of the company
so we can't do that kind of stuff
so we just want to be the secondary
exchange we're very happy with that and
whether you're aware the were the
primary you list with us or you do a
list you still get all the protections
and the substance of our listing
standards and our technology and if you
think about that everything you should
be able to deduce now why that works
from the discussion we had about how
exchanges work at the beginning
exchanges are just portals into a global
pool of liquidity so it doesn't actually
matter where you're listed in terms of
the amount of liquidity that you'll get
and this addresses the number one
concern people have is there a risk is
it risky to do this we have sanded off
all the rough edges of this idea there
is literally no risk we don't there's no
way for us to affect the trading and the
liquidity if you think about you're the
CEO of a private company you're going
public you feel a tremendous sense of
responsibility to your employees so your
long-term investors your seed investors
and these days they will have been your
investors for like 14 years finally
having them have liquidity that's
important to you so we don't get in the
way of any of that stuff we don't get in
the way of the banks and their fees so
we're not trying to reform how how
Osric listings work we support the
company choosing whatever banks and
whatever whoever if they want to pay
cease do you know that God bless so we
take a extreme multi-stakeholder view
ourselves we try to make nice with
everybody we don't fight with the
entrenched powers we try to cooperate
with them as much as possible because
the great thing about this trading
obsessed financial system that we have
is gonna sound funny but actually one of
its great strengths is that people just
don't care what happens to companies
they're not amoral they're not trying to
destroy companies they're amoral they
just don't care so they don't want to be
part of corporate governance they don't
give a crap what companies actually do
day to day when I talk to quantitative
traders I usually do this at a
conversation early on I was sitting at
lunch with a long only investor and a
quantitative trader we were out the same
table and they were talking to each
other about who's more long-term and
whatever and the quantitative trader was
explaining that his average holding
period for his equity they were trying
to get it down to 10 minutes it was like
12 minutes that were working to get it
down to 10 and the long only investor
said that's funny we haven't we haven't
done any transactions this year yet and
the guy was like what what do you do is
like well we bought the companies we
like and we think they're doing well we
haven't found any new companies that we
want to buy and we don't want to selling
the companies we do have so we're just
doing nothing he was like you get paid
for that so I'm sitting with a
quantitative trader and I was like
listen just do me a favor because he was
II was reflexively opposed to long term
ISM anything LTA the whole long term
stock exchange he just just like weii
this is not sound good to me and I was
like let me ask you the question a
different way imagine for me
hypothetically that someday in the
future you have engineered a synthetic
short against a company and today is the
day when the stock price is down 10%
what is engineered at synthetic
shortening yeah I won't get into
training he's great at a financial
derivative or he profits that the stock
price goes down and he's actually
arranged it so that the stock price will
in fact go down so it's not like he
wasn't he didn't just guess lucky he
actually found a way to arrange the
outcome where he will get paid for the
thing that happens if you if you read
like Matt Levine's Bloomberg column you
will learn this is like the hilarious
lengths that people go to including like
entering into these like private equity
type contracts with companies and then
intentionally screwing up the company so
that the company that you invested in
will go down so that your other hedge
position will go up and I mean it's
and Enron famous for this I'm not saying
anything about anybody who does this bar
I understand it's all currently
perfectly legal
anyway the look on his face when I said
the stock was down 10% and he could
imagine himself making things like this
is great tell me more but this
hypothetical I'm very interested now I
was like okay do you realize that the
next day 10,000 managers who work at
this company are running around like
there's a crisis because they have to
change the company strategy and the look
on his face he was like why would they
do that because they all have store term
stock options their stock has just gone
down the ticker has passed judgment on
their strategy and it needs to be
changes like that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard when I short cattle
futures the cows don't care and I was
like right ok I can work with that
that wasn't my first reaction but he
doesn't care he's like look I don't want
it sounds like you're having a profound
impact on the corporate governance of
the companies you invest in and he was
just like that doesn't make sense to me
there's you're just ticklers on a screen
to me just symbols on a screen I don't
care what they do I don't care what they
make I don't care anything that nothing
about the humanity of the people who
were there registered for him and he
wasn't angry about it he wasn't mad he
wasn't trying to ruin these people's
lives
he's a moral not immoral and that's true
for all the everyone who makes money
from transaction volume the truth is if
your company is destroyed but it
generates a lot of transactions on the
way down they're fine
they might even prefer that because they
can just get the next one and we in the
valley we who are adamant in the
innovation hubs of the world we provide
the fresh meat that this system requires
to keep going because it's destroying
companies the company the thing is
shrinking if it didn't have a study so
even at the reduced rates of IPOs now we
still provide the only source of net new
companies to prop this whole system up
in in what they call equity capital
markets in investment banking the jobs
that used to be about rate helping
companies raise money and do
transactions and M&A that whole sector
of banking is shrinking because there
aren't enough transactions anymore for
all the bankers that we have so like the
system is self-defeating unless we find
a way to restore this balance
and allow capital markets to be about
they used to call it capital formation
it's the euphemism for taking money from
people who need something to invest in
and giving it to entrepreneurs who have
a good idea for what to do that doesn't
happen in our capital markets anymore
you know what happens in in totally
different ways so we have to restore
that like primacy of purpose to our
financial system that it ultimately is
about creating value for customers
sharing the benefits in the rewards of
that growth with the general public with
everybody who's truly the long-term
stakeholder in society and then creating
real alignment solving the agency
problem through creating true alignment
between those long term investors and
the managers who are entrusted to run
those companies and so if if I'm a if
I'm a to person come garage idea right
now and I and I'm thinking you know what
at some point I want to take my company
public I really don't want to get caught
up in this stupid quarterly thing and I
really it so what I have to do is I have
to create some charter rules yeah that's
right that follow are your charter rules
all up on your website and you can no
because we're so regulated we have not
gotten to that piece yet so that is not
yet available the the requirements of
listing on the exchange or a matter of
public record they're in the Federal
Register so you can you can go read
about them obviously that we have that
on our website and I actually have a
literally had a fifty-two card deck deck
of cards printed with all of the
different long-term oriented corporate
governance ideas like a collector of
these obscure corporate governance ideas
because because we're not prescriptive
we're not one-size-fits-all I'm not
legally supposed to come in and tell you
hey you should really do XYZ so I now
have a collection of things that you
might consider doing and when I sit down
with founders we literally take the deck
of cards out I should have brought it up
stage which I'm gonna show you and we've
talked about which of these things might
make sense for your stage your industry
your situation and eventually I hope
we'll be able to build that into a
program where starts at different stages
can can adopt these things we actually
on the software side we run the world's
largest I think corporate governance
platform for startups so if any of you
are early-stage companies and you want
and you know we do cap table management
and foreign a valuations and diversity
inclusion and runway planning and all
kinds of concrete specific soft have
said shoot I'm alive you can't sell
corporate governance software to
startups did you notice that no startups
don't buy corporate governance
they don't corporate governance is like
an old-fashioned word that nobody here
cares about so we don't call it that so
sorry we go to market under discreet
brand names for each of the products
that we make but people who are members
of that platform will get first access
when we start to roll out the more long
term Charter stuff that we're talking
about so if I'm not a two-person company
if I'm Amazon and like you know what I
from the beginning we said we were about
long term yeah we want to also list on
this they need to change some of their
corporate governance and bylaws yeah and
then they can apply and they can join as
many people can buy and sell in your
exchange instead of another one yeah
what actually doesn't matter where the
stock is traded you gotta be a little
less but yeah the rights and
responsibilities fall they are emanate
from the Charter and they follow the
security wherever it's transacted so if
you for example if you're an LTAC listed
company one of the technical solutions
that we provide as we allow companies to
identify in real time who their
long-term investors actually are this is
a shocking problem to me the most
corporate boards they don't actually
know who owns the company so they don't
know who to talk to who to listen to
it's it's kind of a wild situation they
literally pay for a service that's
called stock surveillance my favorite
financial euphemisms it's like you're
hiring the CIA to find out who owns your
own company you know you try to like
imagine running a private company that
way you know who your investors are you
don't know what they want it's very
difficult so so we allow them to find
out in real time and then we have a
system that allows them to give rewards
proportional rewards to folks who are
long-term holders versus short-term and
part of the power of a system like that
is it's available to anyone so once you
list with us you can register as a
long-term investor through an existing
SEC regulated disclosure system whether
you're an individual investor and you
bought one share a stock whether you're
big institutional passive fund active
fund you know who any kind of fun
everyone gets the same treatment the
same ability to register as a long-term
investor to reveal themselves and their
preferences to the corporation and that
allows us to solve the problem of the
synthetic stored I was talking about a
second ago one of my dreams is one day
we will have our own stock ticker for
the whole markets and it will just be
the same number going by over and over
again because most days nothing happens
the market is not $1,000 whatever
thousand points less valuable today than
it was yesterday nothing happened today
and like there's a whole industry of
people try to guess what it was was that
the virus was at this was it the
election but like most of the things
that supposedly happened cause the stock
exchange did drop today also happened
last week and didn't cause it to drop so
it's like what is what causes what not
like the fundamental value of companies
very rarely changes on a dime so what we
need to do is take that mindset of
fundamental value and make it available
to more and more companies so that the
investors who then care about that can
be part of the growth of that company
and there but there's no like tripwires
in the system for high-volume fast
trading or anything like that you can
sit you do you have to trade faster or
slower than you do on other exchange
know our particular trading platform is
not especially conducive to
high-frequency trading but we don't ban
it we don't ban shorts we don't ban any
that stuff like this is the other kind
of dirty secret of the financial system
is that long term investors themselves
don't want any restrictions on
short-term trading because they believe
that's the source of liquidity and
they're gonna need it now they're like
family offices and the really long term
people the pension plans the sovereign
funds people who invest on
multi-generational time trades a lot of
those people will tell you you know what
this is all fake liquidity anyway in a
crisis it all dries up none of those
people will be there for you so it's
like liquidity right when you don't need
it but that's a but that's a very
minority view still the long the
majority view of long-term investors is
that's enough insurance after Katrina
like it didn't exist yeah yeah exactly
so I want to get into some questions and
if you have them please send them down
but since Kevin Kelly was sorting the
questions he gets the first one it looks
thank you Kevin for and this gets a bit
too the the question I asked about I
know that you can't say names of
companies that are that may be
interested in your informational
meetings yeah but but kind of what scale
of companies are interested and and have
you have you had to turn any away at
this point
oh that is a really tricky question
because legally speaking a stock
exchange cannot turn anyone away who
meets the requirements so we have to be
fair when we're operational we will not
be able to turn anybody away because I'm
just having informational meetings I get
to choose we would have informational
meetings with and I we do extensive
investigation of the companies that
reach out to us and that want to meet to
find out what they're all about and
whether they in fact embody the kind of
values that we care about and I will not
say that every company we have met has
lived up to that test oh I could there's
a lot of bad stuff happening even in the
valley and you know when we encounter
that stuff we steer clear the size of
companies tends to be not that different
from what you would think of who's going
public like eventually our hope is that
we can eventually return the markets to
sanity have companies go public earlier
or have that not be such a death
sentence have the public we have more
access to growth companies I would like
we want the public to be able to take
risks again as we all understand risk is
correlated with reward and we want have
people like save for retirement they
ought to be able to have a portfolio of
bets that has some risk in it so that
will eventually happen but in the short
term that those effects are a while
while off so almost everyone we're
talking to is either already a public
company or on any of the lists of like
future IPOs that you would look at in
the financial press and in terms of the
archetypes of the different kinds of
companies this is all the really
interesting part the motivation is
really different at like 10 billion
dollars of market cap 1 billion dollars
and then like non Silicon Valley
companies so these are every coming
we're talking to every single one in any
other era in history would already be
public so this is we're in a strange
time you know a 750 million dollar
company is considered small for the
public market staff that's odd so for
companies that are like you know Silicon
Valley companies you know really in the
tech space will have like very like the
really high market cap for them this is
an opportunity to advance their mission
through other means because they have a
real change the world
ethos so then that's not a cliche it's
not a joke they take it seriously and
the really enlightened of those founders
are like how can I use my IPO how can I
use this financial
to help move the whole financial system
in the direction that I think it should
go so the really enlightened long-term
oriented founders you can kind of guess
who I'm talking about they see they have
that vision to say like I don't want to
just run a company I want to be part of
the solution to these wide spread
systemic problems so for them it's an
exercise and trying to figure out like
is this are these values aligned with my
values will this support me in being
able to have the impact but they want
it's like an amplifier of what they want
to do then you have kind of more
ordinary Silicon Valley tech companies
that are not the super high-flying like
biggest they're a little bit more
risk-averse because for them their IPO
is a big deal they really want to get it
right there's a lot of flagging feeling
that oh this is risky or scary but on
the other hand as you get smaller and
market cab the power of hedge funds and
activists like is that the AUM of those
funds is going up and so as your the
amount of money they have assets under
management so the size of a hedge fund
the bigger it gets the smaller of a
target is smaller you are the more
ballast they have the more weight they
have more momentum they have to cause
problems for you
so for them there's our risks on both
sides it's like wait a minute I'm
worried about my IPO I want it to go
well but on the other hand if I don't do
this well I face any protection at all
from these forces the bigger kulluk
computer companies are buffered by their
sheer size the smaller companies are
really really at risk and then you have
the truly normal companies and it's
funny I like the one company in
Wisconsin that we work closely where
there's one in Salt Lake City there's
one in Texas these are not Silicon
Valley household names but their
technology driven companies their growth
companies again in any other era they
would be public and pillars of their
community and for them this is more of a
life-or-death problem their own bankers
are telling them you really can't go
public you know one of the companies we
work with is in the health care space
and there they have this mission to I
won't say too much about it but they
really like they genuinely want to save
the world over the course of the next
several decades and they have a lot of
physical plant but they have to build so
we're talking about like extremely
capital intensive physical things that
have to get made you know the kinds of
things that capital markets were built
to finance and they're being told you
can't go public because you don't have
the governance protections that will
prevent Wall Street from preventing you
from making these
they'll just want to catch this out as
soon as possible is think about that
it's what so thing therefore they're
like well we gotta raise private capital
but they can't just call the vision fund
you know they're there in in actual real
America doing a normal business so like
they don't have you know Petro state
sovereign wealth funds killing each
other to get into those companies so
then it's like well then they have to
raise the money from private equity that
comes with its own trade offs and so
there's literally no solution to them
doing what you would want to do and
again just I want us all to really like
marinate and how ridiculous this is
all of us would want this company in our
portfolio if I could say its name and
you knew what it did and look it's a
high-risk high-reward business may not
work may work and may not work but like
looks pretty good to me they you know
I've done the test things and then
they've done the next size up and
they've done the next size up and
they're on the right track there's like
real physics and science involved in
this innovation it's not just an app and
it's it's difficult to finance because
of nothing wrong with apps listen it's
fine this is the real thing and so like
what's the solution what are we supposed
to do so that for they actually the the
most hard-core of our early adopters the
most evangelical are the folks for whom
that that really is the only option and
is this gonna be better for all of these
employees here in the room I mean we're
living in an era where employees now
banding together at large companies are
actually starting to clearly influence
policy choice aleut leaned towards
environmental directions or or other
directions is what will employees like
this butter I think so I mean listen we
often get calls from founders because
they're like this comes up in our All
Hands meeting people say look is like
most founders most companies here like
one of the corporate values they have is
long-term ism I mean and so you start
telling your employees you wanted to
think long term and people start to be
like well why are we doing the long term
thing and then the in the Hall Hands
meeting they're like I don't know what
that is
and then they're like I better find out
what that is cuz my employees are not
too happy so so do ask if they All Hands
meeting it's really helpful and I think
I think it is very helpful first of all
there's two ways that him this is
important for employees first of all the
rise of employee activism is not like a
passing trend this is gonna get way way
way bigger because corporations are now
dominated by knowledge work
intangible assets which means a relative
power of employees over the corporation
is just it's unparalleled in history I
mean a lot of companies we're talking
about some of the bad companies have no
physical plant they haven't absolutely
no physical assets whatsoever
all the value of the company is
contained in the heads of the people
that work there and you know we talked
about the creativity dampening field and
all that but like they're the people's
creativity motivation sense of purpose
is like one of the primary assets that
the company has so anything that damages
that is really problematic and so
everyone's grappling with like how do we
be a Purpose Driven company and they're
starting to get these questions if we're
so Purpose Driven how come we sell
products to so-and-so to do that bad
thing and why do we allow these things
that'll be asked like genuinely hard
questions that I think other generations
of business leaders wouldn't have faced
so that's like a new new and powerful
thing and so I think if you're in that
kind of company what we hear from
employees is the same thing I was
talking about the public I want the
company to make a binding promise to do
this the company says we won't do this
bad thing we won't sacrifice the
short-term we won't pollute the
environment because it's short-term in
our short term interest we won't poison
our ATCO and customers because that
would be so self-defeating and employees
sit there and they go yeah well you're
saying that what are you gonna have that
job forever
probably not well what about your
successor will your successor also have
that same commitment and make that same
promise and they're like ah surely well
it's always he in these situations I'm
sure he well it's like well why why
would he they're like well he's gonna
have these great short-term stock
options and he's gonna be accountable to
this board of directors who also has
short term stock options and doesn't
especially care about anything but
returning money to shareholders but
he'll have the strength of character I
have no doubt to stand up to that it's
just like what kind of promise is that
and then like yeah is it in the Charter
it's in the bylaws like one of my
favorite in my deck of cards one of my
favorite cards is directors have
tremendous latitude under what's called
the Delaware business judgment rule the
most companies incorporated Delaware to
pursue anything that they think is in
the company's long-term interest they're
supposed to that they have a fiduciary
duty to shareholders but they get to
decide what serve shareholders best and
over what time horizon so they can
choose to say you know what we're gonna
focus on what's in the long term it
company or not is their choice so why
not have boards of directors sign a
pledge to support the mission of the
company that's like three sentences in
the Charter somewhere it's not a big guy
but what are the easiest things you
could possibly do and when you say you
say the tenían point like oh yeah of
course we shouldn't have that but like
go ask your GC if you have that no one
has it almost no companies have anything
remotely like that it's extremely rare
and then you have the read these books
about founders and there's histories
like a common complaint make founders
will be on their deathbed being like my
one regret in life is I forgot to do
that I should have made sure the people
on my board actually supported the
mission of the company and I got kicked
out in the boardroom coup cuz they
didn't care because because because so
like there's these simple small things
that we can do that can make a big
difference the other reason this is
beneficial for employees is employees
are one of the critical stakeholders of
most companies so I even companies that
don't subscribe to the multi-stakeholder
theory of governance like I've met with
a lot of founders I was we were founded
the other day and I was like oh you
should have a stakeholder committee of
the board you should care about
stakeholder he's like that's stupid
stakeholders is done I was like okay how
do you feel about your employees it's
like I would do anything for my
employees
it's like you'd make significant
investments in their well-being oh yes
anything they need I love I like you'd
be willing to commit to that in the
future oh for sure you'd be willing to
have a board committee that oversees
that commitment ah obviously it's like
well how about a human capital
investment committee it's like
definitely that I want that so you know
sometimes we call it one thing another
but like again does the company have any
commitment to the well-being of its
employees is it written down anywhere
are we anything more than it is a
expense to be commodified at the first
opportunity and replaced by robots
most companies I think that's the plan
so you should check if they wrote down
something on the secret plan worth
bringing up at your All Hands meetings
I'm just saying I listen I'm just saying
so I realize we're we're getting close
to time here but I do want to get some
more of these are all so Adam mensches
asks can I invest I assume he's meeting
in you you know TSE in the long term
stock exchange no we're not currently
raising money
we raise a large amount even by modern
standards for a company with no revenue
so I'll just tell you one quick joke
when I first was writing about Lean
Startup and I used to tell this story
one of the first startups I'd joined in
Silicon Valley and the punch line of the
joke is that the company raised 50
million dollars with no customers and no
revenue and then that's like and people
used to laugh it's like oh we know
that's gonna go and now I can't tell the
joke anymore because I like we were like
without the seed round or what it's like
it's not even considered a lot of money
anymore so yeah things things you got a
little we're pretty good at LTI see but
thank you for asking well in cannon
exchange be a public company they must
eventually yeah yeah well we will go
start listening on on the New York Stock
Exchange just kidding we obviously be
listing we will list lists on ourselves
when that becomes appropriate yeah and
does anything protect Joshua asks
there's anything protect investors from
fraud on your exchange that's different
than other exchanges same same as any
other exchange I mean companies are
still required to report quarterly they
still have subject to GAAP
reconciliation those are SEC and
congressional rules that we don't have
the power to change yet and we do
require additional disclosures on top of
what other exchanges require so to
whatever extent disclosure protects
investors from fraud if more disclosure
is better than our exchange is better on
that basis and are there any other like
different technologies or ways of
investing things like using you know
some of these new ledger technologies a
crypto that you guys looked at are even
allowed to do or is it all have to be on
the very normal man highly regulated
financial systems are like so many years
behind so we are the very first cloud
native exchange so for the engineers in
the audience we built the entire thing
on GCP and we tried to get the Google
compute compute cloud so so basically
judge on the Google cloud versus the
Amazon Cloud but the cloud vendors
themselves are not quite ready for those
products to be subject to the level of
regulatory scrutiny that exchanges
require and the SEC is not quite ready
to grant them that permission so
although we are cloud native and
therefore have a dramatically better
structure than the incumbents we still
run a tiny bit of the software in that
data center New Jersey just like
everybody else but just the very minimum
that is required for regulatory purposes
and the very second the SEC is prepared
for an all cloud exchange we will do
that by the way for those engineers in
the room we will be able to then move
from a physical defined network to a
software-defined network and completely
get rid of latency arbitrage once and
for all we can synchronize these yeah
thank you that's right that's what I'm
talking about
a guy I'd ever get some engineers in the
room and not only synchronize at the
level of the millisecond when
information is delivered but at the
level of the individual CPU clock steps
so everyone's algorithm would run at the
exact same moment at the exact same
speed so that is coming but that's still
a few years away and given that cloud is
still considered radical
you understand that there's no drones or
Bitcoin or anything baby steps baby
steps and can use that you've listed a
few of these but I think what would be
the biggest upside like what is the
biggest reason someone would list with
your exchange you can win the public's
trust by making promises they can
believe that's it
and Katherine Fulton from our board I
think this is a great one to to actually
wrap up with all right pass
fundamentally if if you are successful
and this whole thing is working how is
the world give me different ten years
from now
I love the optimism that there'll be any
discernible difference in only ten years
that's awesome let's say a hundred years
yeah I mean we don't know I the
investment thesis for this raising money
for this is really interesting because I
can tell you what will happen but I
simply can't tell you when it's right
like right now we are on track to open
the exchange soon we'll be able to
solicit companies we have something
people love our theme in the near term
maybe next year you know we'll go public
on the exchange but like there's this
concept called the IPO window some of
you will know like the idea that capital
markets are like open for IPOs for
certain amounts of time and then they
closed so like we're like one
catastrophic ly bad tweet away from the
markets crashing any day right so you
wake up in the morning you don't know
what's gonna be so like we have to be
prepared for the possibility that this
happens right away and the movement is
analyzing we get going or that we live
through a long winter before we can make
the change happen but so I don't know
when I just don't know when but here's
what I can't say here's there's my hope
it's not even really about
LTS DNR reforms of course I believe that
companies this next initiative companies
deserve to have a governance model that
really aligns incentives and interests
that employees deserve to work in under
humane working conditions where they can
believe the promises that their own
companies make to them let alone the cup
of promises that they have to represent
to customers I believe that the
investors are long-term investors the
pension funds the people who are
investing for retirement people who
represent the economic interests of
ordinary people
they should be able to participate in
growth companies so I believe all that
is good and can happen but that's not
really what's at stake here to me so
just let me think bigger for a second my
hope is that this because if this works
it will inspire other people to reinvent
the rest of our civic fabric the
institutions that govern our lives in
democratic countries have been decaying
and are practically decrepid partially
from misuse but partially from people
actively hacking away at the foundations
and then being like hey we could use
that for firewood and look nothing fell
over today so I guess it was fine and I
don't think this is like too
controversial anymore
I look around we are not we do not have
the institutions that are fit to purpose
for the 21st century but we also can't
go back our grandparents worked out a
lot of these solutions the hard way and
I just I pray that we don't have to go
through what they went through to build
the next set of these institutions
partly because we have the lessons that
we could learn from the sacrifices that
they made but also we can't just
copy-paste what they did because the
world has actually changed a lot in
three generations so we have to build
new civic infrastructure new you know
stalking the steward about maintenance
new maintainable institutions that make
sense for the 21st century it's not just
bridges and dams whose infrastructure
has decayed but every aspect of our
civil society and I'm talking about
schools and hospitals and newspapers and
political parties and government
agencies and you know defense
departments and everything has to be
reinvented
and the lesson I think of the last 10
years especially is that if we allow
Knology to just disrupt things and just
trust that the market will sort it out
we will like things will be disrupted
and they will be replaced with things
that are new but we may not like the
consequences of that change because if
we don't have entrepreneurs with the
vision not just to build a commercially
viable product or a useful piece of
technology but they don't have the
vision to say there are Civic values at
stake and they need to be baked into the
fabric of what I'm building from the
beginning we don't make those choices
consciously we will get the results that
we deserve unconsciously so my hope is
that LTS C is successful in its own
right but more importantly that it will
inspire many people who are listening or
watching right now to say wait a minute
if it's just a form what's my version of
just a forum right like why do we have
to send kids to school where everybody
learns the same thing at the same time
every day is that necessary why do we
have to build hospital-wide why do we
have to build political parties this way
why do we have to do journal it's like
everything that matters that governs our
our liberal democracies to take a fresh
look and say is there a humane
scientific you know customer-centric
21st century version of that available
and so I hope you know this works it
will inspire many copycats thank you all
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]